jedes jahr verschwinden in deutschland
zehntausende jugendliche und kinder die
allermeisten von ihnen mehr als 99
prozent die tauchen wieder auf gott sei
dank aber einige die bleiben
verschwunden und stellen sie sich diesen
unendlichen albtraum für die eltern vor
sowie die familie und eltern von leonie
gritzka die mit 15 jahren verschwand die
mutter die hat damals gleich gesagt mein
bauchgefühl sagte mir dass leoni etwas
zugestoßen ist leoni war damals 15 jahre
alt als sie in der alleestraße in der
remscheider innenstadt in ein auto
eingestiegen ist und in diesem auto da
saßen zwei ältere männer das auto war
gut und hatte kölner kennzeichen die
mama die hat dann noch eine nachricht
geschickt die nachricht konnte
zugestellt werden aber danach da war das
handy aus und nicht mehr zu orten wenn
sie hinweise zu leonie haben dann melden
sie sich bei der polizei unter 0202
284 7 620
das hier das ist eine junge 15 jährige
aus baden württemberg die seit drei
wochen vermisst ist die polizei die hat
ihren namen noch nicht veröffentlicht
aber sie hat dieses foto veröffentlicht
denn die junge frau die verschwand mit
einem mann und die beamten die sagen es
kann nicht ausgeschlossen werden dass
sie sich in einer hilflosen lage
befindet die jugendliche ist etwa 1
meter 75 groß schlank hat dunkelbraune
haare und bei ihrem verschwinden hatte
sie eine adidas trainingsjacke und nike
turnschuhe an wenn sie hinweise zu ihr
haben dann melden sie sich unter 0781 21
28 1 bei der polizei der nächste fall
armani sie ist 2017 mit ihrer familie
aus dem syrischen bürgerkrieg nach baden
württemberg geflohen und die geschichte
von armani die hätte einer dieser
erfolgsgeschichten sein können denn
armani geht gerne zur schule sie ist gut
in der schule möchte ärztin werben und
verschwindet dann eines tages auf dem
schulweg man hat von armani noch den
schulrucksack gefunden in einem
waldstück und ansonsten verliert sich
die spur wir wissen aus unseren
recherchen dass davor einen großen
konflikt in der familie gab mit dem
vater dass der vater zwischendurch auch
kontaktverbot hatte und die familie
nicht mehr sehen durfte aber was mit
amani geschehen ist das weiß niemand
wenn sie hinweise haben dann wenden sie
sich an die polizei unter der 0 7 3 11
77 47 31 unser nächster fall ist ein
junger mann diane der im august
verschwundene ist aber das macht diesen
fall naja vielleicht spannend und
vielleicht gibt es eben tatsächlich hier
eine hoffnung denn zeugen haben ihn
gesehen am 2 september in osnabrück am
grünen weg und der bushaltestelle am
alten bahnhof diana ist 18 jahre alt 1
meter 73 groß und er hat hier am hals
ein rotes muttermal woran er gut zu
erkennen ist die polizei die ist zu
erreichen unter der 0 802 3 6 11 11 und
dann haben wir noch immer die kleine
enger die am zweiten mai
2015 in ein unglaublich dichtes
waldstück bei stendal gelaufen ist und
aus diesem wald nie wieder rausgekommen
ist wenn man selbst einmal dort war dann
weiß man wie abgeschieden wie abgelegen
dieser ort ist und dass dort eigentlich
niemand zufällig vorbeigekommen sein
kann und dieses mädchen mitgenommen hat
sondern dass dort jemand vermutlich auf
der lauer gelegen haben muss wenn sie
hinweise zu enger haben dann melden sie
sich bei der polizei stendal unter der
03 93
16 8 5 291
und diese fünf kinder die wir ihnen hier
gezeigt haben die sind eben ein beispiel
für 10 15 20 25 kinder die aktuell in
deutschland vermisst werden und wir
haben uns gefragt was passiert denn
eigentlich in so einer lage bei der
polizei die diese kinder suchen und was
kann ich als familie als eltern tun wenn
so was mit meinem kind passiert darüber
wollen wir sprechen mit unserer expertin
mit sandra schmidt die selbst viele
viele jahre bei der polizei war schön
dass sie da sind heute abend und wir
haben gerade über ja schon gesprochen
immer aus sachsen anhalt ein bundes land
wo sie dienststellenleiterin warm wenn
wir jetzt einmal dahin zurück springen
wie ist das für polizeibeamte die
tagelang wochenlang nach einem kind
suchen und dann den eltern ihr kind
nicht zurückbringen können obwohl ich in
diesem fall nicht selbst eingebunden war
hatte ich herzklopfen wenn ich wenn wir
einfach drüber sprechen wenn ich die
bilder sehe und das ist alles wieder
kommt dass es eine erfahrung die die
ermittler und auch die beamtinnen und
beamten die in den absuchen beteiligt
waren niemals mehr loslässt in dem
moment wo man
feststellt dass trotz aller ermittlungen
aller bemühungen die man unternommen hat
das ziel also das kind wohlbehalten in
die hände der liebsten zurückzuführen
nicht erreicht wenn man spürt wut trauer
fassungslosigkeit
fragt man man fragt sich bestimmte dinge
es kommen dauerschleife habe ich alles
richtig macht habe ich an alles gedacht
was habe ich übersehen welchen
zusammenhang gibt es und es kommen
überlegungen wie wie geht es dem kind
heute wo ist es was macht es gerade wie
groß wäre es jetzt
ist es tod lebt das also fragen die man
nie wieder los wird weil man darauf
keine antworten bekommt das ist eine
erfahrung die ein bis ans wahrscheinlich
ans lebensende beschäftigt
[Musik]